hey what's up my understanding leads and
I'm a property investor I make a lot of
money in property and the purpose of
this YouTube channel is to help you in
your property investment journey so
here's Joe happen I am about to answer a
load of questions from last week's video
all of the niggly questions are coming
up in the comments right now on their
answer them but here's the great news if
you're watching this video now I'm going
to be answering your questions in the
next week's Sunday video so what I want
you to do is listen enjoy and
frantically comment all of your
questions below in this video also
please don't forget to smash that like
button and if you're not already to
subscribe to the channel turn on the
subscribe button turn on the
notification button below because I
might answer your question next week and
you wouldn't even know because you did
work subscribe so subscribe
turn the notifications bow harmed and
let's see what we've got
so Robert son of Adam says is there any
way of getting rid of ground rent or
overpriced service charges they are
crippling some of the great potential
return on investments if you're buying
an apartment
you are only a lease holder you don't
hold the freehold which means that you
don't own the land you just party just
own the actual flat itself so you will
have to pay ground with no service
charges because someone's ultimately got
to pay for the for the gardening for the
maintenance of the building someone's
got to pay for the elevate and the lift
if there's one in there so you have no
control over that as a lease holder so
you can already get round it the only
way you have control over what that
amount is is if you that there's a like
a board committee board but to be honest
if you're looking at buying a property
and it doesn't stack up because of the
lease whole because of the ground rent
or service charges I would just say just
walk away from it because you're not
really gonna have much control over this
I hope that questions Robert some of
Adam Bruin are says my thing I'd like to
know are you able to find tenants
without listing a property with them
estate agents say yes you are is it so
is it easy is it worth it and how would
you go about doing it legally with a
contract and all that
oh is it easy music worth it I mean
listen there's this whole thing about
whether something's easy or not is it
easy well yeah you can do it it's like
anything isn't JA it's any job easy it's
just a case of putting the time aside to
do it there's nothing
rocket science like about it or really
hard is it worth it it depends on you
you'll save a little bit of money
because you won't have to pay an agent
but then you will also have the work
especially in the first instance of
firing the tenant setting it all up
depending on how much your time is worth
if your time is really valuable in your
in a high-paid job or you've got a
business and you're really busy and you
really pay well pay someone else to do
it also depends on whether you want to
do because you might want to do for the
learning aspect so how do you go about
doing it so the basic things you're
going to do to find the tenant you can
advertise tenants yourself so you can do
that on companies like open rent Cody UK
where you can take pictures list it
advertise there it's very cheap you can
get a property on write this so I'm like
fifty quid I rent your property for
about fifty quid so it is easy with the
contracts you don't need an AST contract
which you can get for very very cheap
online in the ninety contract you're
going to register the deposit which
you're doing my deposit code at UK there
are certain checks and stuff you need to
look at I mean is it worth it for me no
but I did it when I started out because
I wanted to learn and I wanted to save a
few pounds so it depends on your
situation but if you're going to do it
definitely make sure that you do lots of
research you can get most of this
information online so in terms of your
responsibilities as a landlord you can
find a lot of that online so yeah that's
my answer I hope that helps Paul preffer
I said Leah would you go to help me out
with this please let's say I get a ready
to rent do five bedroom six rent or two
thousand per month renting there out of
five tenets of two thousand five hundred
fifty question is do I need to pay tax
now only on the net profit five fifty or
in the whole amount
2550 if I do have to pay tax on the
whole now there'll be no profit left
after paying all the tax no you don't
have to pay tax on the whole amount you
just pay protection your profit if
you've got a renter and you get paid tax
on the whole way that's crazy you pay
tax on your profit and if you just
started out in business you don't pay
any tax on the first I think it's eleven
thousand pounds to the first eleven
thousand pound profit you make in a year
is tax free and then after that you'll
start paying tax and sliding scale I'm
not tax accountant so I can't give you
financial tax advice you know on this
channel because I'm not qualified to do
so and because
no new exact situation but you pay tax
on profit and it's your job to work out
what the profit is so that's the answer
but you know what you've said here that
you've got if you were if you were
paying two thousand pound a month from
rent and then you're renting for two
thousand five hundred fifty your profit
wouldn't be five fifty you'd actually be
less than that probably because I'm sure
you have other costs I mean this example
of the deal is probably not a good deal
because that 550 a month you have one
empty room you've got if you've got to
pay the bills he pay you you're gonna
have some expenses so you want to see
much more cushion than that but you're
only gonna pay tax on profit if take
care hüseyin when do you need to produce
a business plan when getting into
property would it be after two
properties I'm asking this because after
three houses I'd like to stop working
and make property my main business I
think you need a business plan right
away personally because if you're just
buying one house and it's just that
you're an accidental landlord you know
no you don't need a business plan if
you're serious about property if you're
serious about being a business person an
entrepreneur obviously you need a
business plan and when we do our our
advanced training you know I tell people
that a business plan workout where you
are
woke up where you want to go a plan of
how you're gonna get there steps risk
versus reward you can do a SWOT analysis
strengths weaknesses opportunities
threats yeah you seriously don't if you
want to be serious throw a dabble and
Bob one or two houses and that's the
plan but I would say stop say start as
you need to go on don't be an accidental
landlord start as you mean to go on and
get a business plan in order but at the
same time there's been so much time
planning that you don't do any doing
when I say get business plan I'm not
talking about spending weeks or months
writing a dissertation and spreadsheet
and you know plan plan plan plan plan
plan plan you got a plan do review and
repeat that so that's my answer
Aaron hunt so question within deal
packaging what happens if no investors
on your email list are interested in the
property are you then responsible for
letting the agent know you were no
longer able to purchase the property and
does this involve losing any money
you're a massive inspiration thanks for
the help thank you okay here's how you
want to do this and this is something
that we do teach on our training I
reckon
getting down training I'll leave a link
for the property investors crash course
below it's free it's two days I'll be
there so just go on serious if you put
enough on a house and the agent says
offer accepted and then you try and sell
the house but you can't it's very
awkward having to then go back to the
agent and so sorry I'm gonna have to
pull out we can lose any money you're
not gonna lose money know when you will
damage your reputation and you will
damage the reputation of deal sources as
a whole so it's not good so what I
usually do to get around this is rather
than putting forward a formal offer and
then waiting for the offer to be
accepted and then selling the deal is
I'll have a property and I'll put in a
bit of a tentative offer so I say listen
you know if I was to offer 85 what do
you think they'd say I said if wouldn't
offer it's not a confirmed offer if they
say yeah you know what I think they'd
probably accept that you have to come up
a tiny bit higher but you close then
what I'll do is I'll start putting out
feelers to my investors and say hey I've
got property this is the description
bang bang bang these are the figures and
I've got it and it's looking like I'm
going to be able to secure at 90 grand
who's in and then when I've got a few
people are hungry in two dimensions I'm
interested in I've got some interests I
say okay look I'm very crispy in this
rap job have you got them and I'll get
these guys ready then I'll go back and
I'll put in a serious on fat 87,000
they'll come back and say eighty seven
and a half or whatever and then I'll go
hey guys 87 half who's first
if you play your cards right and you
dribble between the two and although
that sounds like a lot of effort when
you get good at this and you only have
to do the first few times because when
you have a list of really high investors
you just know exactly what they want so
you don't have to do this in the early
stages when you're starting out or code
your sauce there's someone else selling
the deal for you and go 50-50 on the
profits but it's worth it because the
average deal sells for about two or
three thousand pounds you do that once a
month and you've replaced an average
income so people won't think well that
sounds so hard but you do want a month
and then you take the rest of the month
off if you want I hope that helps all
right Dan told charred lifestyle it's
all the movement of property the rent on
gaining will be the same as the mortgage
after we finance what should I do
Sal don't refinance because if a
property is not making any money then
it's not an asset and we call this
washing its face so if it's losing money
it's a liability it is making
NASA if he's just breaking even it's
washing his face I wouldn't refinance it
and then let it wash its face I would
sell it personally and then reinvest the
money into something that is an asset
that's my general advice but I'd need to
look into the specifics oh don't you
know don't make a decision just off of
that because I don't know much but
that's my general strategy hi Samuel is
this smart to invest in real estate in a
third world country or should I move to
another country like the USA UK or even
Germany that's a great question and I
haven't invested in a developing country
but I mean I've been tempted because I
do I do I travel a lot and I've seen
people and met people I've made crazy
money I think if you play your cards
right if there's a country that's just
yeah I mean just developing and at the
moment it's you know third world I don't
know that other that's be correct to say
that I'm not sure but what I'll say is
this invest in where you know my
strategies that I teach work pretty much
globally I mean at least 80 90 percent
of what I teach works across the board
you can apply into your country however
I only invest in the UK and the reason I
invest in the UK because I know that you
can really well like the back of my hand
is a smaller Island I get it if I start
investing overseas whether the laws are
slightly different
I don't know the areas at all it just
makes it if I was going to do that I'd
probably really research the country or
the area first but yeah I mean you could
make money I've met people that make a
lot of money in developing countries so
if that's where you're from and you know
the area go for it but the world you
always got my friend fanny he says
entrepreneurs are they made or born both
if you want to be a great entrepreneur
and become like a Multi multi Multi
multi multi-millionaire you probably
have to have the natural fire and burn
and the training I make the making you
need both if you want to be a property
entrepreneur become financially free
even if you're not born I believe
because I see all the time on winners
Wednesday and my students I believe you
can you can I can help phone people to
become an entrepreneur where they become
financially free they become decent
entrepreneurs make a good living I don't
think that ball and I think you can do
that or if you're born an entrepreneur
you have no training but you have a
natural flair you could probably become
okay we
but you wanna be great you need to be
natural and you need to be made and if
you're not naturally an entrepreneur if
you're a bit of a reserved person and
you know we with training are a hundred
percent believe that you can become
successful can anyone become a Multi
multi multimillionaire
even if they're not born with the
natural flair and the natural fire in
their belly maybe not okay that's
question so balmy place tango how are
you do you invest in any other asset
class other than property if so please
let me know yes I do I invest in
property owned best in business I have I
have a business I'm a training business
I have an agency just a property it's
actually a business I also invest in my
personal brand right now
I'm investing in my personal brand the
guy who's behind filming that he he's a
videographer that I'm investing in Matt
in paying his salary but that's not
really property that's more my personal
brand because I believe that it's not
what you know it's who you know but even
more than that it's who knows you and by
me document my journey and do these
videos I'm putting myself out there did
whenever I am I then get deals from that
I've grown my property business so I do
invest in other things other than
strictly property I have a little bit of
crypto and I've dabbled a little bit in
stocks and stuff but again going back to
my previous thing it's the best thing to
invest is the things that you know the
most and for me I just get property
again it I'm really really good at it
it's bricks it's more tracking see I can
feel and touch it goes up in value over
time I can rent it out and get anything
from it I can borrow money to buy
property so I just get it and because I
get it
that's what I am blessed in it and I do
think that it's property is one of the
best investments besides yourself
so me investing in my personal brand
mean vesting in my education investing
in me is the best investment and then be
investing in property I'm investing in
business and brand and you know that is
what I invest in investing what you know
but if you look on the similar times
rich list most of them are in property
and that's what I think property is also
just great so that's a wrap comment your
questions in below if I didn't answer
your question comment it below thank you
so much for watching please do subscribe
because I know
so watch the videos and they're not even
subscribed to subscribe
turn the notification bell on smash the
light then I love home see you next time
thank you so much
[Music]